In this video we will do some sample exercises
to solve equations. You will see that these equations
require several steps, perhaps a little more than those,
which we did in the previous video.
Then we will solve a text task,
where we will apply our skills to solve an equation.
So here we have 7 w </ i> plus 20 </ i> minus w </ i> .
Let's see if we can solve it.
As usual, there are different ways to solve the problem.
I will do it the way I feel most comfortable.
What I will do is
to make the endorsements.
If I do the operations, I get 7w </ i>
then subtract w </ i> from them.
Maybe I can somehow use w </ i>.
So * 7 (w + 20) * I can write as * 7w + 7 times 20 *.
Let us remember the properties of "distribution".
This is * plus 140 *.
And then we have this * minus w * is equal to 5 </ i>.
I rewrote this part here.
And I distributed 7 </ i>.
And just as I said, we can unite -
we can take 7w </ i> and extract w </ i>.
So both will remain 6w </ i>.
If I have 7 </ i> of something and drag 1 </ i> out of it
I will remain 6 </ i> of the thing.
So I got * 6w plus 140 *
is equal to 5 </ i>.
Now, I want to remove this 140 </ i>.
Because in then I will get 6w </ i> equal to something
and I can divide everything into 6 </ i>
To get rid of this 140 </ i>, I can pull 140 </ i> from both sides
of the equation.
And I'll do it in pink.
Minus 140.
Now just take 140 </ i>
on both sides of the equation.
If something is equal to something else, the first * minus 140 * follows
is equal to the second * minus 140 *.
Whatever you do on one side,
you have to do on the other side.
The point here was to cut the left side.
What is left on the left is 6w </ i>, which is equal
* 5 minus 140 *.
That is, -135 </ i>.
Now we can divide the two sides of the 6 </ i>
which is like to multiply by 1/6 </ i>,
hence, w </ i> is equal to -135/6 </ i>.
Can we simplify this result?
Let's see.
This number is not divisible by 2 </ i> and does not appear
be divisible by 3 </ i>.
This means we have solved the task.
And now we can check our answer.
Actually, let's check, because
this number is somewhat weird. Is that the answer?
So we substitute in the initial equation: 7 </ i> times -135/6 </ i>, which is our solution
for * w + 20 *.
Instead of 20 </ i> I will write plus 120/6 </ i>
20 </ i> and 120/6 </ i> are the same thing, right?
Minus w </ i>
And w </ i> matches -135/6 </ i>
If we subtract a negative number we get it
collecting his positive, right?
And that's what's happening.
This becomes 7 </ i> multiplied by ... see -135 </ i> plus 120 </ i>
is -15/6 </ i> plus 135/6 </ i>
Let's see what happens.
Hence 7 </ i> multiplied by 15 </ i>.
Let's do it.
How much 7 </ i> times 15 </ i>?
This is 70 </ i> plus 35 </ i>
That is, -105/6 </ i>
Everything's OK here
Plus 135/6
What's happening?
It remains 30 </ i> divided by 6 </ i>, which is equal to 5 </ i>.
And that's exactly what must be equal. (According to the original equation)
Our check is 5 </ i>, that is, -135/6 </ i> is the answer you are looking for.
My sixth sense lured me.
Our decision is right, even though we received it
this strange result.
Let's now look at this task.
First, we have parentheses, the number 9 being exported to the front.
In fact, we do not need these brackets.
There are different ways to decide.
We will probably do them in two ways.
So the first way is to open the brackets,
so I will not deal with the division of 9.
So we open the braces and multiply: 9x minus 18
is equal to 3x plus 3.
Now we have to get some of the hikes together on one side of the equation.
Let's collect them from the left.
That is, we try to get rid of this 3x, which is on the right side.
And the best way to remove it is to pull out 3x
on the right.
But if we take an action on the right, we have to
we take it on the left too.
So we take out 3x on both sides.
On the left remains 9x minus 3x is equal to 6x, we rewrite
minus 18, and on the right is equal to 3x plus 3 minus 3x.
We cut from right 3x with -3x
left 3 on the left side.
There are now many ways to make a decision.
It's a lot of fun - let's do it
in the most common way.
We can add 18 on both sides, thus -18 will be shortened
on the left side of the equation.
And there will be 6h, these two are getting shorter, eh
equal to 3 plus 18, which is 21.
By dividing the two sides into 6, we get for x that is equal to 21/6.
or by dividing the numerator and the denominator into 3
we get 7/2.
And we're ready.
As I said at the beginning, there is plenty
ways to solve this problem.
Let's do it another way - in orange.
That is, we have 9 times x minus 2 is equal to 3x plus 3
Okay, here I see a ninja and I see some threes.
What happens if I divide both sides of the equation to 3?
By dividing the whole country into three shares all
positions in the equation of 3.
What do we get?
3 times x minus 2 is equal to x plus 1
In this place, if I want, I can open the brackets.
And I get 3x minus 6 equals x minus 1
I could get x on both sides of the equation, so
i will get 2x minus 6 equals 1
You did remember that I took it out on both sides, and so on
it disappeared from the right.
I can add 6 on both sides of the equation.
I get 2x is early on 1 plus 6 which is 7.
I divide the two sides to 2, from which it follows that x equals 7/2.
I went through this method a little faster.
But I really wanted to show you that while I was doing
acceptable actions, the same answer will be obtained.
And you can check if it is
the right answer if you want.
We now have a text task.
Let's see if we can resolve it.
Lydia inherits a certain amount of money,
It divides them into five equal parts.
Let us call with m the amount of money it gets.
Let's say, this is Lydia's money,
which she inherited.
And which she divides into 5 parts.
She invests 3 pieces of money in a bank account with high interest rates.
How much do I invest in a bank account?
It divides the money into 5 parts and invests 3 of them
into a bank account with high interest rates.
So she takes her money, divides her into 5 parts
This is each of its 5 parts.
She then invests 3 of these parts, or it can be said
takes 3/5 of her money and puts them on a high-interest bill.
which is increased by 10% of its value.
That is, it is the quantity it puts
actually put it in the bill.
She invests the remainder of her heritage plus $ 500
on the commodity exchange.
And so
how much in this?
So she puts the rest of her heritage.
That is, she leaves 3/5 in a bank account with a high interest rate.
What is left?
It should be 2/5.
2/5 of her money is invested
on the commodity exchange, right?
If you collect 3/5 and 2/5, you will receive the entire amount
money she has inherited.
But she has not put only 2/5.
She puts the remainder of the heritage, which is 2/5 m
plus $ 500 on the commodity exchange, but loses 20%.
So ... that's how damp and how much
gets finally.
That is, here is an investment, and here a Final Payout.
So, bank accounts add 10% of their value.
That is, it starts with 3/5 of the money they bring
another 10%.
Let's add them: plus 0.1 times the amount of money,
which she has invested.
that is 3/5 of her money.
That's how it's done.
Final payment is its initial investment plus 10%
of the initial amount invested in the bank.
She has a 10% birth rate.
It adds 10% of its value.
Now for the commodity exchange, it starts with 2/5 m plus 500,
but loses 20% of that money.
That is, it loses 0.2 times 2/5 plus 500.
This is the amount she lost on the stock exchange.
It loses 20 percent.
Finally, if these two accounts are completed, they say
with an equal amount of money in them, then
what is the amount she inherited?
That is, and this must be equal
and we are looking for a solution for m.
Let's do it.
We take 3/5 m plus, let's see this is the same
like 1/10, right?
Let me write it this way.
1/10 by 3/5 is 3/50.
Plus 3 / 50m is equal to - I just multiplied 1/10 with 3/5
is equal to 2 / 5m. I want to write it
in the same color - in orange. is equal to 2/5 m plus 500
0.2 is the same as 1/5, right?
0.2 - let me write it here is equal to 20/100,
which is equal to 1/5.
Let's transcribe here as 1/5.
So 2 / 5m plus 500 minus 1/5 times 2/5 plus
5 2/5 m plus 500.
This is a tricky task, but we will look at it step by step
and we will see that this is not so bad.
For example here, let's add 3/5 of something
plus 3/50 of something.
Okay, 3/5 of one thing is not like 30/50, right?
If we multiply the numerator and the denominator by 10.
Now let's add it
30/50 plus 3/50 is 33/50 m is equal to let us be forgiven
2/5 m plus 500.
We open the brackets by multiplying to 1/5 and getting -2/25 m,
and then -1/5 multiplied by 500 is minus 100.
Let us forgive even more.
The left side is still 33/50 m equal to
and now we have these coefficients multiplied by m
here
These are our 'm'
It can be considered as 2/5 minus 2 / 25m.
so here's what they're saying:
I just pulled m in brackets.
So, we have 500 minus 100
That's 400.
Let's see.
2/5, if we multiply the numerator and the denominator by 5
this becomes 10/25.
No?
Thus the equation becomes: 33 / 50m =
10 minus 2. How much is this?
So, 8/25 plus 400.
We're almost ready.
Let's move m to the left
side of the equation.
So, take out 8 / 25m from each side.
I did it, and on my right there is no m.
The right side is equal to 400.
And so on the left we have 33/50 minus 8 divided by 25.
This is equal to 33 divided into 50 minus 8 divided by 25.
8/25 is the same as minus 16 divided by 50, right?
I multiplied the numerator and the denominator by two.
m = 400.
We're almost ready.
This is a good job!
Here ...
So 33-16 is 17, right?
So we stay with 17/50 equals 400.
So we can multiply both sides
with the opposite of 17/50, that is
50/17 multiplied by 50/17.
We delete them, and we get m equals,
let me get my calculator ...
me equal to 400 in 50 divided by 17
is equal to $ 1176.47
So much money had Lydia at first.
I hope you enjoyed this task.